status report incoming Shinji Katya is
currently in a critical state and
undergo a knife saving surgeon C
protocols have been instigated citizens
are advised to remain calm the
government has issued a nationwide state
of emergency the status has been changed
to Code Red
currently commencing citywide
evacuations completion five hours the
Angelus started drilling from directly
above looks like it'll penetrate the Geo
Front soon I'll penetrate your geo but
soon so it's trying to hit a centre home
looks like this is it guys it's
do-or-die time
okay people we need a plan how much time
until penetration according to my
calculations we have about 12 hours
until penetration is that accurate
actually according to my calculations we
only have 10 hours till penetration well
according to my calculations you don't
have any calculations according to my
calculations you're a [ __ ] hey stop it
boy according to my calculations my
massive bone is ready for penetration oh
god damn day without referencing your
boner what can you tell me about the the
Angels currently drilling hard and fast
into us with its long rod expected to
penetrate our barriers with that deep
hole bored into us we'll be exposed
right from behind against his massive
load out
mikoto yes ma'am slap him ah aerial
attacks have been ruled out along with
close quarters combat he'll be
constantly shifting making it extremely
difficult to neutralize on top of that
unit 0 and unit 1 will be operational
for quite some time so in other words
we're basically screwed we are not
screwed I gotta [ __ ] die Walmart we
can try self-destructing the
headquarters and taking the angel with
us yeah that sounds like a great idea
sorry was that sarcasm I heard oh that
was sarcasm
you do realize that sarcasm is the
lowest form of wit yeah well your mom is
a gay stinky poopoo head super I stand
corrected
come on people we know the situation
looks dire but it must be something we
can do you try saying a white flag we're
all out of options it's all gonna die
anyway why can't we just go home already
yeah well that's just great guys why
don't we just in here with our thumbs up
our asses waiting for our enemy dude so
everyone else could go all the launch
anime really no there is one option left
s SDF research documents you requested
to come through right does that mean the
attacks
giant saver iPhone I think we have
access okay great we'll go with that now
that that's started everyone get ready
to start operation check
kick-ass guys operation kick-ass we can
hear you
we just think it was [ __ ] stupid tell
me again what's so stupid about this
plan besides the fact that there's less
than a 1% chance of success to this
mission top latkes are sticking with it
unless you know something else that I
don't I'm pretty sure I know a lot of
things that you don't preparations for
the operation are almost complete
waiting your orders to start testing
colonel good now assuming that
everything went according to my plan
we're almost finished you do know they
say the de sumption for the mother of
all screw-ups no I'm pretty sure they
say assumptions are shut up I'm only
trying to help you
Reed Zuko can you just trust me for once
without questioning me at every turn
start the test so you know how they say
assumptions are the mother of all
screw-ups
shut up well at least this can't get
worse you did make sure that Cindy would
still pilot the AVA right
Oh finally awake ray what happened you
just went through surgery I'm afraid
they found something wrong with your
penis
what uh what was it you have one at
least I think that's what they called it
and will you hurry up and get dressed
you haven't Ava to pilot so they expect
me to pilot it again really after all
I've been through after all the pain
they just want me to know what you need
to do Oh get some tampons drink a bit of
cranberry juice and go see your
gynecologist I think you're starting to
menstruate again how could I men
straight if I have a penis that's a good
[ __ ] question so you really don't
care if they just use me or you to
Pilate till we die I want you to do
something oh okay look at my face okay
just look at it ray no no keep looking I
am looking no you're not look harder is
there a point to this yes
so look as hard as you can all right
focus on every part of my face all right
all right I'm doing it now does it look
like a give a [ __ ]
are you coming on to me again is there a
bigger idiot than you on this planet she
was totally coming on to me again you do
realize we're currently under siege from
an angel attack right do you know what I
call that type of woman the ones I just
won't leave you alone this is gonna be
really tasteless isn't it
unflushable cuz they just keep floating
around you and we please focus on the
matter at hand
wait are you thinking what I'm thinking
god I hope not
unless you want to stop calling this war
the fights against Giants I don't
understand what the problem is you're
kidding so the world changed after the
second impact right correct and because
of that we're fighting these giant
things called angels right so what's
wrong with calling this war the fight
against Giants because uh you be calling
the most important war ever in human
history the [ __ ] I still fail to see the
problem is there a bigger idiots than
you on this planet
hi Cindy please don't ask me Masato what
do you mean ever since I got in the AVA
everything went bad I get hurt I get
shot nobody appreciates it
nobody likes me my life sucks and I'm
always in danger so please tell me
you're not here to ask me to pilot da ba
all right
I'm not here to ask you to pilot the AVA
you're here to ask me to pilot the AVA
aren't you oh [ __ ]
I'm not doing it come on Shinji I've
already had enough trouble convincing
Ray's ago to go with the plan yeah why
don't you try convincing me the same way
then [ __ ] you'll listen to me I could
do that if you wanted what's the point
nobody really cares about me why are you
even here
look Shinji come with me listen if you
don't defeat the angel what do you think
will happen what do you want me to do to
it disappoint it to death I'm just a kid
here there's something I want to show
you we saw it oh yeah
what the hell is that giant white thing
nailed to a cross Jesus what kidding
this is the second angel Lilith and it's
the reason you're fighting if an angel
manages to get down here all life as we
know it will end what do you mean it's
up to you to protect everyone if you
don't do it then we're all doomed why
are you telling me all this
Shinji you may think I don't care but I
want you to believe in yourself more
than anything everyone tells me to just
be stronger like it's so easy it's all
my got a want to but what if you pilot
the AVA you can't prove your strength
nothing ever goes right once I get in
everyone just sees me as some joke
you're pretty right about that but you
know what you've pulled through every
time and we're all still here because of
that no matter how bad things get I
trust you'll do the right thing
do you really mean that if I didn't do
you really think I put up with some of
the biggest idiots in the organization
for fun then why do you do it because I
need to because humanity needs us and
because I trust you we survived the
second impact filthy Ava's we've endured
and do whatever it takes survive
together so please shinji for us for me
you have to pilot unit one again all
right I'll do it
only if you let go of my hand No Deal
okay we've only got one shot at this so
we need to do it right that's why I put
Shinji in charge of the sniper wait you
put the food of the entire world on him
fan-fucking-tastic now here's the
important part Shinji once we're locked
in position unit 1 will not be able to
move so I can't run away you can't run
away I can't run away
you can't run away I can't run away what
can't you do
I can't run away not helping raise
gentie would you just grow some balls
for once in your life and stick to the
plan
it's lantry's with me this is a bad idea
is that correct Rae yes it's correct
akari's balls haven't descended yet hey
do you know what your problem is Shin do
I think you're starting to menstruate
again why does everyone keep saying that
okay that's enough everyone get ready
for operation kick ass operation kick
ass is that really the best name you
could come up with oh I'm sorry
but operation Shin ji has a massive
vagina was already taken Siri that time
in the hospital when I was unconscious
were you just sitting there watching
over me the entire time while I lied
there naked I was assigned to look after
you until you woke up way to make it
sound creepy though pervert you weren't
doing anything while I was naked right
don't flatter yourself
were you expecting me to masturbate over
your naked comatose body or something oh
you were one special boy you know that
special Yeah right running away is my
only specialty really with an attitude
like that I would have thought it was
getting mad [ __ ] we might die soon
you know it'd be nice if we could be
friends after you sexually assaulted me
called me a [ __ ] and told me to make
you a sandwich why the hell not well
from what I remember you also slapped me
for that oh did you think that was a
slap I thought I was just high-fiving
your face bro thank you look ekari if
you want people to like you stop being
an idiot if you want people to respect
you then don't run away but what if I
die before then what if I freeze up and
cry like always then that will be that
and nothing will have changed if you
want to cry then tonight I will show you
how it can rain with tears of scarlet
target is stationary and all sectors are
ready
operation kick-ass commencing
preparations are complete
it's up to you colonel okay people once
again Japan is under attack and once
again we all stand on the brink of
destruction some of you may be numb to
it by now
some of you might not really care what
happens some of you make this doesn't
get me the hell off but for once I'll
ask you to remember for this day tonight
if there's one time we'll work together
it's tonight if you're plotting that
everything goes right it's tonight if
there's one time we'll win it tonight I
want to start the operation okay
commence operation kiss-ass what this is
really not the time to go get a fully
charged okay isn't it the entire world
is resting on your shoulders
okay okay
fire
the cannon has been successfully fired
on enemies not shitty you energy spike
on the enemy detective right Colonel I
must inform you that through my years of
knowledge and expertise working at the
station I can conclude that we are
[ __ ]
I must concur with this statement guys
go [ __ ] yourselves
on a scale from one to [ __ ] how [ __ ]
are we
I'd say we're pretty [ __ ] any one of
you anymore very fun ha
I recommend that we switch to our back
apply it sir think so the main pilots
been compromised we know we can't give
up on him yet no matter how bad
can you hear me
remember everything you said brought
awake so many templates
my problems from my fears everything
but not this time I'm tired I'm useless
tired of running father I won't do it
anymore I won't let you down run away
are you sure yeah all right one more
time
got it
yes he does what
No
jerm second impact happen way to laugh
angels attacked and we built a bajillion
we're here together we'll survive
together just who do you think we are
Oh
if you want to cry then tonight I will
show you how it can rain with tears of
scarlet Brie
ray are you alright ray uh oh god please
don't tell me you just saved me that's
it I thought you said we could have been
friends after this you actually took
what I said seriously
how else would I are you really gonna
start crying after everything you did
shut up it's a nervous condition okay
you know if you're gonna see the girl
you could buy her dinner first or at
least start with some small talk well
we've been having some really nice
weather recently I enjoyed the scarlet
rain you showed me
here let's go home still doing I guess I
was just lucky today
yeah finally awake well good the Angels
attacking humanity's in danger
your dad's waiting for you and everyone
needs to do pilot unit one it's time to
gain the robot ekari oh you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me I'm a cab you're
[ __ ] embarrassed gorgeous just shout
that I shout the [ __ ] lighter hold it
what the boner say that I am [ __ ]
Aereo on assure I have to deal with this
my boner cannot take it let the phone
art God coming as if I'm afraid of some
little Xillia matter ah and what you
landed us peanuts Oh God soldiers
hey that's good it's gonna be a really
do I just know it I was assigned to look
that I was assigned to look coffee I was
assigned to this is really taking a toll
on my throat